well for more than a hundred years the
Boy Scouts have been a pillar of
American life but today they're gone
they disappeared the Boy Scouts from
America announced he'll be changing its
name to scouts BSA to reflect his
decision last fall to admit girls into
the program Girl Scouts I don't think
are admitting boys the organization is
also launching a new ad campaign
intended to appeal to both sexes the
tagline is scout me in which maybe not
surprisingly sounds like one of Hillary
Clinton's many campaign slogans author
and columnist mark Stein joins us
tonight for a post-mortem on the death
of an American institution this feels
mark kind of like a watershed moment
maybe I'm overstating its importance I
don't think you are Chuck oh one of the
interesting things is that Boy Scouts
were so universally presumed to be good
that the very name became a synonym for
being the good guy that's right the ago
the first time any of us had heard a
James Comey 90% of colonists and
commentators said Oh James Comey is
renowned in Washington as a boy scout
that's what it meant the good guy and
the genius of the left is that in
nothing flat they turned the good guys
into the bad guys I remember going to
the Democratic convention in Los Angeles
in the year 2000 and some scouts came
out bearing the flag and the Democrats
on the floor booed and I thought my god
these guys are crazy they're booing Boy
Scouts well shortly after the decision
in the 90s not to have gay Scout masters
they got kicked out of church halls
companies like Disney said that their
employees could no longer give the
charitable donation through Disney to
the Boy Scouts basically the good guys
were turned into the bad guys and that's
why they rolled over on transgender
scouts they rolled over on Girl Scouts
and now they've driven a stake through
the heart of the institution and it is
dead it's happening on a larger stage of
because Harvey Weinstein was a pig the
rest upset to stand back and not say
anything as masculinity is criminalized
but something's lost it yet I think
and I want to ask you it's this that's
making me so depressed that I gotta move
on to something happy I'm sorry the Boy
Scouts that just it's one of the last
wholesome at least in my mind places for
boys so like where else do they go I was
a lousy Boy Scout Tucker so you could
have it was well enough to be a Boy
Scout
I was slouched shouldered and
long-haired but I always admired anyway
Nancy Pelosi on a happier note says
she's sticking around on Tuesday the 78
year old Democratic leader says she
plans to run again for speaker if the
Democrats win the house and they may
Republicans love the same way Democrats
are terrified but here's my question
why are Democrats so afraid of danceable
say they don't want her to speak her at
all but none of them will say that to
her because she holds his mystical power
over them why well I think that's what's
in crimey said things that would take
out any normal politician you know we
have to pass the bill so you can find
out what's in it she's in favor of open
borders and yet at the same time she's
in favor of mandatory contraception use
so that no Americans were already here
have any children she's a mass of
contradictions and inane statements but
unlike Republican leaders she's a
ruthless operator and you're gonna if
you're a Democrat and you run up against
the Nancy Pelosi it's something to work
out too well for you she's she's serious
and she's telling them back off because
when we win in November I'm gonna be the
speaker don't get in my way
that is absolutely a massive
contradictions and inane statements but
as the daughter of the mayor of
Baltimore she knows how to count votes
and she's tough and toughness in the end
is decisive I think you're absolutely
right and also don't think it's sort of
a measure of how weak a lot of
Democratic members are that they're
afraid of a 78 year old former Speaker
oh well actually compared to a lot of
people on the Democrat side she's
actually a young whippersnapper
you shouldn't be ungallant tucker bernie
stippled is is you you said the Boy
Scouts were a hundred and eight years
old I think a Bernie Sanders was
the original members back in whatever it
is 19 19 10 so so compared she she is a
beautiful young thing compared to most
of the Democrat is a young pioneer for
the record but whatever so that's right
let's think it is speech to high school
kids today Michelle Obama said this
watch I know that you are me and if I
can be standing here as your forever
horse lady then you can do anything you
put your mind to you are me
where'd it brought it back to me but
whatever I I don't actually like the
idea of you know there's a term for a
forever first lady it's Queen I think
there's something odd Republican about
this when I hear it in context like that
though I do wonder if she's just reading
out some sappy schlocko soft rock song
because that's what it sounds I know
that you me your mouth arrival first
lady it's number 37 in 1988 it was Kenny
Loggins or somebody like that so there
James Taylor John Kerry flew James
Taylor to sing it to the head of the
Paris bombings your mouth for rim of
first lead it's a great song but but
it's only it is on Republican the best
term for me for Michelle Obama is mrs.
Obama the best I don't believe in this
practice of extending governor and
Senator Titus for life you verify counts
and dukes because because senator and
governor and titles like that are in the
gift of the people I agree with draw
them you go back to being mr. and mrs.
and if you can't take my I'm not calling
you doctor no I totally agree mark we're
doing a remix of that song that was apps
that was I'm speechless
thank you oh yeah yeah it's a it's a
great so number 37 in 1988 ask Casey
Kasem it was a huge he's God now thank
you
great to see Marc
thanks taco